hola buenas tardes y tal y como
comentaban las relaciones entre la unión
europea reino unidos siempre han sido
complejas pero los líderes de las
asociaciones europeas han recordado sin
lugar a dudas la gran importancia de la
figura de isabel segunda un papel que ha
ejercido con con paz con credibilidad
una persona enormemente respetada aquí
en las instituciones europeas la
presenta la comisión europea a ursula
von der leyen ha enviado una carta al ya
rey al rey carlos en que leen en que
recuerda el gran papel que ha ejercido
su madre la reina isabel segunda también
el presidente del consejo europeos ni se
le ha tenido unas palabras en memoria de
la reina isabel segunda la ha recordado
como la reina isabel segunda la
inquebrantable ha recordado el apodo por
su firmeza y por ser un gran portero por
su gran papel en la construcción del
siglo 20 y también del siglo 21 la reina
isabel segunda vivió las conflictivas
relaciones
entre la unión europea y el reino unido-
recordemos de hecho la reina vivió la
entrada del reino unido a la unión
europea en 1973 y vio cómo salía en
enero de 2019 relaciones aún así muy
importantes pero que todos los líderes
en situaciones han recalcado su papel
siempre conciliador también la
presidenta del parlamento europeo robert
a med sola ha recordado su gran papel en
este sentido así que mucho pesar también
aquí en las instituciones europeas tras
la muerte de la riqueza de la segunda
esther por poner un poco de contexto a
la audiencia a ella como jefa de estado
mantenía unas relaciones de digamos
fuera de la política y mucho más
plenamente institucionales y de ahí esa
es la imagen que se recuerda en bruselas
sí sin duda ella era la jefa de estado y
eso siempre se ha respetado de hecho
siempre se ha tenido que mantener al
margen aunque siempre se ha considerado
que claro ha tenido que escuchar siempre
en las negociaciones lo que decían sus
primeros ministros theresa may boris
johnson vio el referéndum del brics en
2016 como lo anunció también david
cameron y su posterior renuncia a la
reina isabel segundo ha visto la
construcción de esta relación y también
la el divorcio de la relación entre
reino unido- ella como jefa de estado
del gobierno de jefa de estado no puede
no no se podía pronunciar aunque dentro
de bruselas hace unos años hace escasos
cinco años siempre se vio con un poco de
jocosidad cuando la reina isabel segunda
una vez se vistió para asistir al
parlamento británico de color azul con
un sombrero amarillo algo que mucha
gente interpretó como un apoyo a la
unión europea a su bandera